I'm a sucker for a pretty face.
Actually, we all are.
Why is that?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Anthony here for D News.
And over and over,
studies show that humans
seem to attribute
positive personality
traits to physically
attractive people.
Integrity,
intelligence, kindness--
we just think that prettier
people have those things
by default, whether
we realize it or not.
It seems unfair, and it is.
But is there some sort of
biological reason for it?
A recently published study
from Cambridge University
wanted to find out just that.
They selectively bred
silver foxes for 20 years
based on how friendly
they were towards humans.
And with each generation, they
got more and more domesticated.
And as they got
more domesticated
and as they got
friendlier, they also
seemed to acquire more
physical traits that would best
be scientifically described
as-- oh, look at their adorable
little faces-- rounder skulls,
smaller noses, shorter muzzles,
flatter faces.
It turns out that
friendliness in silver foxes
is connected to genes that
control the hypothalamus,
pituitary, and
adrenal glands, which
all modulate fear
and aggression.
And as those genes
changed, the physical
features they're responsible
for changed, too.
So what does that mean?
It means that we associate
cuteness or attractiveness
with physical traits
that also mean
something is less dangerous.
It is a survival thing.
We know to be
attracted to something
that is less likely to
tear our throats out.
Handy.
Now in humans,
the idea of beauty
changes from culture to
culture, and everybody
has their own personal type.
But there are some
traits which have
been found to be attractive
to the majority of the world.
And it could be
that we're not just
wired to find those
things attractive,
we are wired to find
those things attractive
because we are also
wired to find them safe.
It's one of those left over
survival skills that actually
hinders us in day to day life
because humans have much more
complex brains and
thought processes
than we did in the wild.
Those attractive
traits don't really
correlate to anything any more.
You know, I basically avert
my eyes from pretty people
and just give them
whatever they ask
for as I stammer out a thank
you to them for allowing
me to be in their presence.
How about you?
Do you automatically think
highly of attractive people?
What is wrong with us?
Let me know in the comments,
and subscribe for more D News.